と 今までの説明は今までの経典から出しましたからわからないんですね
これはまあ人間にわからないのですからね
ですから まあ我々にわかる言葉で言えば
個人が自分の生きるパターン
一人一人が持ってますよと
そのパターンのことなんですね
自分を他人を観察する
で 我々は自分のことも他人のことも観察した方がいいんです
で 世の中でやっていることとちょっと違って
自分の観察も大事なんですよ
時間をかけて 本当は年単位ですけどね
人の行動パターン 判断パターン
思考の方向性を観察するんです
人のこの仏教でいう性格を発見したければ
年単位で人の行動パターンをじっと見た方がいいんですね
それから考え方 判断の仕方
いろいろ見た方がいいんです
同時に自分の観察も客観的にしてみる
それから自分の行動パターンは何なのか
自分の考え方はどんなのかとかね
自分が判断するとか 今まで今 5年かけていろんなことを判断してきたでしょうと
その判断はどんなものでしょうかと
よくよく見ると なんとかパターンが見えてくるんですよ
自分の思考でも観察してみると
何かパターンがあるんですよ
そのそれが性格ということになるんですね
何年もかけて見ると 何かパターンがある
それで性格の型が見えてくると思います
これも本当は推測で お釈迦様とは似てないんです
それを知っておけば その人との関係を持つ場合
どうすればよろしいかということ推測できます
そこで人のパターンがわかったら
どう対応すればいいかわかるんですよ
例えば 奥さんたちが子供か何か問題したところで
それお父さんだけに言わないでくれとか言う場合あるでしょうね
お父さんのパターン知ってますから
この人何すればわからないんだよと
また他の問題を起こしたら
じゃあお父さんに言ってやると
いきなり私は知りませんとお父さんに任せたりもする場合ありますね
それは夫婦で長い間一緒にいるんだから
もうパターンがなんとなく見えているんですね
だから この問題はお父さんには言わないことにする
この問題だったらそいつに任せという
それでいくらかうまくいきます
一切は無常なので 因縁によって変わるので
最終的に決めることはできません
パターンが見えても決めつけてはいけないんですよ
なぜならば 何でも因果法則によって変わるでしょうに
だから 人の生活 例えば 40年間生きてきたパターンでも
何かの原因で変わることはあります
仏教はどうせ変えますよ
性格は そのまま放っておけません
全部良い人間には変えちゃうんです
無常でなきゃこれ成り立たないんですよ
もし魂でもあったならば
どうしようもないんです
そのまんまでいなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
ありがたいことに 魂の霊魂とかなんとか何もないんだから
もう何でも変えられます
人の欠点をなくすために良い方向へ
これ この善が間違っています
これは善ですね 善の方向へ進んでもらうために努力するべきです
そこで私たちは何のために人のパターンを知りたが知るべきかというと
その人の欠点を直してあげて
良い方向へ 善の悪の方向ではなくて
善の方向へ人を導かなきゃいけないんです
その責任あるんですよ
大人には 先輩には後輩を正しい方向へ導くという責任がありますからね
だから性格知っていた方がよろしいのです
難しいかもしれませんが
変わらないものはありません
性格パターンだから変えるのは難しいかもしれませんよ
そう簡単に人は自分を変えられ変えません
もう言っても言ってもね
自分の性格になっちゃうんですよ
難しいんだけど とにかく頑張って
もう良い方向へ持っていかなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 変わらないものっていうのは存在しない
唯一期待できるのはその無常なんですよ
変わらないものは存在しないんです
決める前に 能力とは何ですか？と
能力はないという問題あるでしょうね
今日のテーマはこれからなんです
で  能力はないと 能力ないと決める前に
能力って何ですかね？知ってますか？随分軽く能力はないとか能力あるとか言うんですけど
たくさん能力の種類があります
能力といえばいろんな種類がありますよ
たくさん能力あるんです
一つだけじゃないんです
それで我々間違えるのは
能力という単語一つだから一個だと思っちゃうんです
一個じゃないんです たくさんあります
能力っていうのは 一般的に言うのは
そのたくさん能力を見たら
一般的に言うのは 人が決めた目的に希望通りに達することができることは
能力 才能というべきだと思います
だから結局我々能力というのは
人が決めた目的に簡単に達するか達しないのかということ
達するならば能力があるという
達しなかったら能力がないという
例えばピアニストになると決める
ピアニストになったならば
あ 能力がありますねというんです
頑張ってもピアニストにならなかったならば
能力はないと ですから
能力っていうのは まあ目的に達する
達することができるかないかっていうぐらいの話で
それで目的たくさんあるんだから能力もたくさんですよ
ピアニストになる能力ある人が
あのレーサーに あのなんとかレーシングカーありますね
あの車  F1 レーサーになれるかっていうと
冗談じゃないんでしょうに
あんた能力 能力ないと言わなくちゃいけない
しかし ピアニストだから能力あるでしょうに
ピアニストになる能力あるんだけど
F1 レーサーになる能力はないんですね
だから能力はたくさんです
その定義なら仏道にも俗世間にも合います
この定義だったら この 3番目の行に書いてる定義だったら
俗世間の能力ということも説明できるし
仏道の能力の問題の説明はできます
目的に達するのか あなたはと
目的に達しないんだったら
能力はないんだと 目的達しないなら
達するならば能力があると
それで仏教はそれでは我慢しません
目的に達しない人も達しさせるんですよ
いわゆる能力向上を教えているんです
目的に達しなきゃどういうことかと
もう最悪でしょうに 全能力はいらないということを覚えておいてください
いわゆる全ての能力は要りません
この世で何でもできるとはありえないし
それは要りません 何でもできる人間にならなくてもいいんです
大変困ります それに何か一つ二つできれば十分です
何か人間なら何か一つ二つできれば
これ十分ですよ 自分の能力生かしちゃえば十分です
全部できるっていうのはありえないし
多種類の能力がある人は実際は不幸になってしまうんですよ
あれこれいろんな能力がある人っていうのは
本当は大変で生きていられなくなっちゃいます
何にも落ち着かないんですよ
バイオリンも弾きたいし
ピアノもやりたいし 会社も経営したいし
それで政治もやっていると
選挙にも出るとかね むちゃくちゃでしょうね
議員になってからも演奏会やっているとかね
どちらでも動けなくなっちゃいます
時間の問題もありますからね
それで国会で音楽のことを喋ったりする可能性もありますよね
迷惑ですけど あのおじいさんって寝ているんだからね
で それで演奏会に行ったら政治論を喋ったりする場合もあるし
ですから この多種類の能力があるとかなり困りますよ
これが仏教から学んでください
俗世間ではもうこれがいいことやと思ってますけど
実際はみんなダメになっちゃうんです
能力を生かす 2つ必要それで十分です
十分役に立ちます 社会というマトリックスの中で自分の位置をわかれば幸福です
この社会という複雑な構成の中で
じゃあ私はこれやと 私はピアニストやと
私はバイオリニストやと
私はコックさんやと 私は百姓さんやという自分の位置があるんですよ
それで止まれば 社会も安全で
本人も安全で生きていられます
それから能力の開発 仏教は能力ないというのを決めつけませんだから能力の開発ということは考えてはいます
でも仏教の能力開発というのも解脱するためなんですよ
商売繁盛のためじゃないんです
この方法は 商売繁盛とか社会の会社の経営とか何とかに使っちゃうと
ちょっと問題が起こるんです
なぜならば この社会の会社の経営はうまくしたいと思っちゃうと
この能力をダメになる原因も入ってくるんです
だからこの使う場合は結構気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
1妄想を極力やめる 妄想っていうのは実体性ない思考ですね
これはもうすぐにやめられますよ
具体性がない考え方はやめると
時間の無駄 エネルギーの浪費
これは時間なくなりますからね
それで力がなくなるでしょうに
それで能力開発できないんですよ
事実現実見えなくなるんです
だから目的に達するためには
事実現実見えてないと目的に達しないでしょうに
バイオリニストになりたいと言っても
その世界でもかなり厳しい競争がありますから
現実を見ないと ただ夢だけでは叶うわけじゃないんです
妄想をやめた方がいいんです
ありえない期待 願望 計画を立てる妄想のある人は
いつでも期待 願望というのはありえないものですよ
だから達しないんですよ
だからまず妄想をやめるということになるんです
心が汚れて退化するんですよ
妄想すればするほど 心が汚れて汚れて汚れて退化するんです
だからこれ とっても危ない原因なんですよ
妄想するっていうことは
妄想するイコール能力の能力が蝕む
妄想がすればするほど
能力が減って減って消えてしまいます
力が発揮できないんです
妄想すると もう力が出てこないんですよ
だから 第1 それ妄想をやめる
素直でなくなるので何も学べない
妄想する人は素直じゃないんですよ
頭の中でぐるぐるぐるぐるとなんかもう火事のように
山火事のように妄想回転しているんだから
何も学ぶことできなくなっちゃうんです
データが入らないんですよ
それならもう能力というのはありえないでしょ
だから能力開発  第1 は妄想やめること
第2 時間を徹底的に短くするっていう
ちょっとわからないんで
これはね 次に説明します
今日 1 日何をできるのではなく
今何をするべきかと考える
理解する 発見する 時間的に今日は何しようかではなくて
今何するのかと 今何するべきかと
それ発見するんです 理解するんです
1 日の計画は置いておいて
今何するのかと それが時間を短くするということなんです
そうすると見事に能力が向上していくんです
結果は将来的なことであっても
その仕事に対して今何をするべきかということは大事です
今行うべきことについて
心も体もスムーズに動かせる
ということで 例えば東大出て官僚になりたいというのは
これはかなり遠い将来の話でしょうに
それはどうでもいいんです
今何するのかと だから
そういう遠い将来の計画があっても
それは置いておいて それ向かって今何するべきかと
それだけやれば達しているはずなんです
すごいシンプルですよ
これやらないんだから
みんな期待はあるんだけど
叶わない こういうやり方だったら
期待は確実に叶います
妄想してないんだから
ありえない期待も作らないんです
なんでそんなこと言うのかというと
能力というのは自分の目的に達するかしないかということなんですよ
だからこのやり方しかやり方はないんです
それで今やるべきことを発見するでしょうね
スムーズにそれやる 簡単によく動かすんですよ
体も心も で  3番目 私は部品を作るというわけもわからない言葉なんですね
で これから説明に行きます
私たちは全体を構成するものではありません
自分が行うべきパートがあります
自分の役があります 我々はこの世の中で全体を構成している神様ではありません
私個人があるパート ある部分
ある部品を作っているだけです
個人の立場が お母さんでいえば人類を育てるわけじゃなくて
ある一人二人の人間を育てるだけです
だから私っていうのは部品を作ってるんです
全体の これを覚えておかないと
その部品をしっかり作ればいいでしょう
自分 自分が作る部品 演じるべきパート
それに集中して完璧にこなすんです
私の仕事は小さな部品を作ることやと
ネジを作ることやと それも 3 ミリのネジやと
あるいは 4 ミリのネジやと
これしっかりと 4 ミリで作っちゃえば
自分の仕事終わってるんです
能力あるんです それで
例えば私は 4 ミリのネジが必要で買ったところで
あれ ちょっと長すぎとかね
で 困るでしょうに それであの人からネジ買っちゃうとぴったしやと思うでしょ？しっかり作っているならば
これは日本の社会の現象からこういう言葉にしたんですけど
いろんなところで 小さな町工場で何か一つ部品だけ作ってるでしょ
それにしっかり凝ってプロになって
もうビシビシと作る だからあっちこっちからいろんな国々から注文出すんですよ
あの会社の部品だったらもう OK やと
信頼できるんだと その会社の人にとっては
自分の部品を持って何作るのか
それは関係ないんです
しかし 一つだけ自信がある
自分が作った部品にはクレームが来れないんだよと
人生はそういうものなんです
我々は全体を作っているわけじゃないんです
部品を作っているんです
こう世の中で平和築けないのはそういうわけでしょ
世界平和を謳っているんだからね
個人の部品だけやれば
自分が平和のために貢献するところだけやれば
世界平和なんですよ このパートやってないんだから
世界は戦争ばっかりで
だからこの全体的に考えるとかなり問題なんです
全体的に考えるということは
あんまり成り立たないんです
しかし そこ世間ではよく言うでしょ
これ全体的に考えてくださいとかね
本当はこれおかしいんです
人のことまで考えられないでしょうに
だから会社の何て言いますか
あのインフォメーションとかの受付あるんですよね
そちらに座らせた女の子は
会社の全体的なことはどうでもいいんです
そんなのは 自分が受付だから来る来るお客様のことどうですか？とか
こんにちはとかね いらっしゃいませとかね
それだけやっちゃえば完璧ですよ
すごく役に立ちます それでなんのことなく
あの子にはすごい能力がありますよと言っちゃいますよ
だからこのパートやっていることって
パートっていうのは このアルバイトのことじゃないんです
パートということなんです
部分部品はやってる 家の奥さんが奥さんという役柄を演じるんであって
旦那の仕事の役まで演じる必要はないんです
学校に行ってね 先生たちに教え教え方まで教える必要はないんです
自分のパートを発揮しておけば
どこでも問題は何のことなく解決するんです
次 喜び 充実 また間違っています
充実感ですね これかじゃないんです
喜び 充実感を感じるように計らう
これ 自分の個人的な問題です
何やっても喜んでやってほしい
ニコニコと 私はよく笑ってください
よくヒューマーを大事にしてくださいとよく言うんですけど
どんな真剣なことをやったっても
ちょっとそこを冗談言ったり
笑ったり 楽しくやった方が能力は向上します
充実感を感じてほしいんです
理由は 脳はご褒美を期待しているんです
我々の脳っていうのはご褒美が欲しがるんですよ
それあげないと動かないんです
だから神経質になってガリガリ状態でやっても
能力はなんとか口なんとか巻いて
もう必勝とかね なんとか精魂とか何とか書いたりして意味がないんです
あれでは能力は減っちゃうんです
喜んでやらないと 脳にはご褒美が必要なんです
ご褒美があると頑張るんですよ
またわかる 役に立ちました
よくできました うまくいった
無駄ではなかったなどの信号が脳に必要なんです
あの文字間違いはたくさんありますので
あの それは皆様の能力になりますから
自分で直してください
だから我々個人個人が自分にの脳にそのご褒美あげてください
あ 良くなりましたと 無駄ではなかったと
あるいはもう誰の役にも立たなかった
自分一人だけやった よくできました
できましたとかね よく覚えてください
それが大事なこと ポイントなんです
ですから 何であろうとも無駄をやめる
だから脳にご褒美はないんだから
無駄っていうことは全部やめた方がいいんですよ
無駄と感じたらすぐやめた方がいいんです
無駄なことをやると能力が退化するんです
勉強しなくちゃいけないのに
漫画を見ていると本人も無駄だと知ってるでしょう
単なる刺激だけで能力は減るんです
そこで読みたいんだけど
読まないとそれを舌に出して勉強しちゃうと
なんとなく脳があ お前よく頑張ってるんじゃないかという風に
脳にご褒美が入るんです
何かをやるときは その意義
必然性を探してください
なんでこれやるのか どんな意味あるのか
こんなことをやってとかね
それ発見するともうやる気が出てくるんです
ただ言われたんだからといってやるんじゃなくて
みんな言われてから言われたんだからやる性格でしょうね
だから能力っていうのはほとんどもう成長してこないんですよ
仏教はこういうところをすごく強調するんですね
意義あること 有意義なこと
意外に絶対やってはいけない
それでもうどんどん能力向上します
意義があるとわかったら
もうご褒美 その時点からやる気が出てくる 5
番目 他人に対する慈しみがあれば
鍵の馬鹿力というものは自然に現れます
能力というのはそういうことだからね
すごい能力やと驚くほど能力は出てきますよ
慈しみであれば なぜならば
我々は人間関係で生命関係で生きているでしょうに
野菜を作る人でも みんなに美味しいものを食べさせてやるんだよと
野菜嫌い子にも自分が作った野菜を食べさせるではないかというふうに
それは相手に対して慈しみを持ったりすると
うまく能力が開発できます
わが身のことだけ心配すると何もできず退化します
野菜を作る人でも 自分のことだけ考えて
これにお金売って もう簡単にもうかる
商売するそうとか何とかとか
自分のことばっかり考えちゃうとうまくいかないんですよ
退化します 会社にしたっても
まあ自分のことばっかり考えちゃうとすごく苦労するし
能力は退化します 自分の利益のみを徹底的に考える人も
苦労 批判 非難などに無関心に努力して成功するが
道徳的に問題があります
時々 ものすごくわがままで
自分のことしか考えない人々は
会社に入ってももういろんなことをやってやって
とにかく課長まで上がったりはするんだけど
道徳的にすごい問題があるんです
その人は課長までなるのはものすごく苦労の結果なんです
人の批判なんかは全く無関心でいたことなんですから
だからそんなのはもう能力でもなんでもないんです
人ということを無視して
もう自分でなんとかやって
とにかく課長まで上がったとしても
いろんな悪いことをするんです
その人は自分の目的に達するために
その道では目的に達しても能力はなし
ただ苦労しただけ  6番目
思考の整理ということ
妄想家でも思考はありますからね
それを整理するんです
私のすべては私を何を
私は何を考えているのかなんですね
こちらで決められる これを覚えておいてください
What you think is what you are
自分が何者かということは
自分が何を考えているかということなんです
だから思考を整理すれば
思考で全部決めちゃうんですよ
ポジティブで他人のまた
役に立つように 有意義的に
慈しみに基づいた思考ができるようにする
それで思考を整理して
ポジティブにして 思考をね
それで他人の役に立つよう思考を考えて
他人に迷惑をかけることを考えてはいけませんよ
それは罪です 人に役に立つことを考える
有意義なことを考える
慈しみに基づいて考える
それが思考の整理なんです
皆様が考える整理じゃないんです
こういう風に整理してください
思考 自分なりに整理したっても能力にはなりません
この整理の仕方で能力になります
これ 6番目 能力開発の 7番目
結構ありますよ 欲 怒り
嫉妬 何でしたっけ？憎しみ
恨み 高慢 過剰な自害意識などは人を行進させる
堕落させる感情です 離れる
これがあると堕落するんです
俗世間ではそう思ってないんですよ
欲望も仰ぐんですよ 怒りを仰ぐんですよ
ライバル意識を仰ぐでしょ
それで頑張ってもらってるでしょ
でも結構苦労しているでしょ
頑張ってもすごく苦労して
何か目的に達しても能力とは言わない
能力というのは 楽々に遊びながら
笑いながら目的に達するということなんです
自分が動く衝動は その感情にならないように気をつけるんです
働くかな 何でした 我々は怒りで
例えばスポーツをやっている場合は
相手の学校に対してすごいライバル意識を持って
あの連中にはもう負けてたまるかとか
怒りでやってやってます
たとえ勝っても ものすごく苦労して勝ってるんです
スポーツ自体がすごく嫌なことになっちゃうんです
それで才能を発揮できなくなるんです
有益的に持っていくんですよ
やっぱり学校のために
みんなのために もう勝たなくちゃとかね
勝ったところで まあお母さんも喜ぶでしょうとかね
学校のみんな喜ぶでしょうとかね
一生懸命私が育てているんだから
これやらなくちゃという風に
怒りではなくて その慈しみで有意義に思考整理をしていくとします
心の明るさ 軽さ 柔軟性を保つ
いつでも硬い心じゃなくて
すごく明るい心で 軽い心で柔軟性があっていなくちゃいけないんです
それっていうのはもう考えておけばそうなるんですよ
8番目 価値観を変えるということ
知ってますか？我々は命かけてやっているすべてのことは内職に過ぎないのです
みんな命かけてスポーツだって命かけてやっている
仕事 命かけてやっている
なんだこれ くだらんでしょうね
そんなこと 専業主婦やっている人も命かけてやっているんだとか
冗談じゃないことを 全部内職やと思ってください
朝から晩までやっているもの
いわゆるやってもやらなくてもどうでもいいんですよ
それで世界は滅びることはないんです
仕事は人生ではありません
やることは何でも内職感覚でやって気楽にできますよ
人格向上のみが本職です
これ価値観変えれば まあみんな能力の達人ですよ
こう価値観変えてみてみてください
私の生きる目的は人格向上であって
どこかの工場で労働をやっていることじゃないんだと
人格者になることが本職であって
朝から晩まで会社に行ってやる
あれは内職であると 私は辞書を調べてこの単語を入れたんです
もう  9番目 でも8番目とても大事ですよ
執着の障害 この執着っていうのはすごい代物で大変なんですよ
何かに執着をすると進歩
発展がなくなるんですよ
止まっちゃいますからね
慣れた仕事なのに別な仕事を命じられると
執着者は途方に暮れるんでしょ
会社が変わっていっちゃうと
自分の仕事を別な仕事に自分を変えたりすると
まあ執着する人っていうのはもう途方に暮れて
もう暮れて もう苦労してものすごい苦労するんですよ
だから執着しない方がいいんです
人生は毎日新しい経験
新しく学ぶことがないと損だと思ってください
毎日何か経験がないと損だよと
新しい経験 毎日何か新しいものを学ばなきゃ損だよと
そうなっちゃうと執着がなくなるんです
人は向上 するんです 能力は開発するんです
人生っていうのは毎日何か学ぶことやと思っちゃえば
別に会社でね 15年同じ仕事をやっていても
別のものに入れちゃってもね
全然気にしない それやっちゃって
です 最後です 恥ずかしいことではありません
人にはできることも苦手なこともあるんです
これは性格から出てくるんですよ
できることもあって 苦手なこともある
それは恥ずかしく思う必要ないんです
パンダカさんのお話したでしょう
あれも第 80代阿羅漢の一人なんですよ
しかし 芸一つ覚えられません
皆様はサバパパアカラのとこ覚えているでしょうね
あの方にできません 忘れちゃいます
しかし 大阿羅漢なんです
恥ずかしくないんです
それは 苦手でできないことに欲張ると皆に迷惑でしょ
苦手ことはもういい加減やめてほしいんです
俗世間の能力にリミットがあります
それで俗世間でいう能力
仏教でいう能力 2つですね
仏教でいう能力っていうのは
人格を向上して悟ることなんです
リミットないんです 俗世間に仕事をできれば十分ということで
そちらにはどこまでというよね
リミットがあるんですよ
例えば 品物を売る人はノルマつけられちゃって
数字だから 8個売りなさい
今度は 200個にしなさいと
今度は 2000個に 言うのは簡単ですけど
リミットがあるでしょうに
例えば 各家を訪ねて売ってるだったら
あんた 1 日 100軒訪ねてくださいったって
ピンポン鳴らして走るしかないでしょう
だから能力にはリミットがあるんですよ
俗世間ではそれ知っておいてほしいんです
しかし 人格完成解脱を体験するまで納得してはならないのです
本職ですからね 本職の場合は完全になるまで納得してはいけません
内職の場合はそこそこでいいんです
そんな程度ですよ 能力開発は
守るか守らないかは別として
一応これは異論なり立たないブッダの方法なんです
すごい科学的で心理学的なんです
で 仏弟子から学ぶということ
お釈迦様に様々な弟子たちがいました
80人の大弟子は一人一人何かが桁違い能力を持っていました
あまり皆様は知っているかどうか分かりませんだけど
いろんな阿羅漢たちがいて
お釈迦様はこの名誉格を与えたんですよ
例えばサーリプッタ尊者は智慧第1
目連尊者は人相第1だということは
人類の中で全ての生命の中で
その人はトップなんです
お釈迦様決めたんだからね
しかし 一人一人能力は違いますよ
今日思い出したエピソードなんですけど
あの人相ある目連尊者とアルルッダ尊者か
他の誰かのもう一人  80人の一人なんですけど
でいて そちらにサーリプッタ尊者もいるんですね
そこで喋ってますよ 目連尊者がいろいろなんとかガキ道のなんとかガキはね
この間こういうことを言いましたと
それでなんとか君はこの間ね
こういうことをして言ってて
私はこんなことを言いましたと
でももう一人の坊さん
まあそうですかね 私もこの間
そういえばですね そのあなた会ったがけに会ったことありますよとかね
二人でしゃべるんですよ
サーリプッタ尊者がお釈迦様の 2番目で一番トップなんですよ
サンガの中でサーリプッタ尊者にその能力ないんです
サーリプッタ尊者 素晴らしいことですね
こんな友達がいて 私には地縛霊も見えませんよと
いわゆるこの一番レベルの低い霊のことで
地縛っていうのは私が入れたんですけど
まあ地縛霊でしょうね
日本語にするとさえも見えませんと
これ恥ずかしいことじゃないんです
知恵のことになったら
もうサーリプッタ尊者が第1だから
だからそれぞれ人々にはそれぞれの能力がありますよ
だからサーリプッタ尊者がこの超能力開発とか霊能力開発
それはもう苦手でやらないんですね
マハーヤナ宗では ギリ細かくブッダの真理を因果法則を分析で教えてやると
これはあまり苦手でやらないんですよ
だから お釈迦様の弟子たちの例でお釈迦様は我々に教えているんですよ
弟子たちもバラバラだから
能力は しかし 悟りの場合はみんな同じなんです
本職の場合は 内職の場合はバラバラ
悟りの場合は皆同じでしたが
俗世間的なレベルではで能力は様々でした
だから我々もこのそれは覚えておいた方がいいんですよ
だから内職は内職で 本職は本職ではっきりした方が
ですから この世で何でもできなくてもよい
よろしい しかし 何もできないとことはダメですね
何でもできなくてもいいんですが
何もできないということはやめてください
それで一応終わります
というわけで まあ一応我々は何か一つや二つや三つぐらい
あまりたくさんじゃなくて
そこまでもう有意に頑張ってみれば
それが能力ということなんです
それは内職でしょ いくらなんでも
本職っていうのは立派な人間になること
心の煩悩をなくして悟ることは本職です
それがもうずっとやるという方法です
では まあそれで話を終了します
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます